I want to be your assistant
really you hate it here so do you I'll
make sure you don't have to go to any
meetings if anyone comes to see you I'll
scare them away wait April if you had to
choose between these two ties you're
hired
I just figured I might as well get paid
for being here ten months ago she was an
intern who could give a craap but local
government now she's our newest employee
it's April yeah cherry come and
celebrate no thanks well everybody let's
get back to work
where are you going I want to talk to
Ryan about the size of my desk Jerry you
have to schedule an appointment okay how
about now Ron's not here he's right
there I can see him I'll let you know
when he's available and a girl morning
lovelier oh man I am so tired
I took a half-shift at the hospital last
night and I had this really weird
patient weird how I probably shouldn't
talk about us one of the grossest things
I've ever seen
talk well this guy came in he got his
hand stuck in a Pringles can and he
tried to cut himself out did he use
three and a half inch serrated buckets
of blood he passed out over his arm and
slumped onto the floor with a bunch of
very good question April answer her yeah
the bone showed everyone in the universe
loves a gross medical story boom I win
and so when I finally clean up the vomit
I found the toe I forgot about the tail
or did we crazy right story is awesome
indeed thank you for sharing Jennie
Anne was getting a little chummy when
people get too chummy with me I like to
call them by the wrong name to let them
know I don't really care about them
that's a genius move thank you you're
welcome
Lester Carson RAC confirming what
that's not possible oh no hey good
morning why are there six people outside
who say they're waiting to meet with me
so you know how you love me because you
haven't had a single meeting with anyone
since I became your assistant that's
because every time someone calls and
requests a meeting with you I always
schedule it for March 31st why because I
didn't think March 31st existed thirty
days has September April March and
November June and November today is
March 31st you know so then how many
meetings do I have today 93 okay okay
well you know what to do right
to me this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape however to Leslie
Knope
oh why don't you take as many as you can
and I'll cover the rest I have a better
idea why don't I try to rustle up seven
more meetings cuz I think it would be
cooler if there were a hundred why don't
we just stick to these 93 and see how it
goes
yeah well hello there you must be Ron
Swanson Oh welcome to Casa Ludgate hello
mr. lucky ah call me Larry Susie's boss
Oh Rowland read-aloud gate oh you have
no idea how nice it is to meet you oh
come in for God's sake what can I get
you to drink Oh could you take your
shoes off please thank you so much
nothing to drink Thanks Oh April around
you have a guest I'll fetch her she's
probably on I'll come with you okay
you make yourself at home mr. Swanson
thank you you must be April's sister I'm
Ron hmm nice to meet you why are you
here
come back to work no come back I want
you to come back well I don't want to
come back the end I was talking to Andy
about you and he made me realize that I
need you back at work what did he say
don't recall fine I'll come back good
okay I'm leaving bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver my mom has all your
albums I recognized you the day we met
have you told anyone no good girl Oh
Lilli excuse me I had a meeting with Ron
Swanson yesterday but had a little car
trouble sorry he's busy right now oh
well what can i reschedule sure hmm how
about June 50th sorry do you think you
could come back today at 265 he's
available then what is going on looks
like the only other day he has open is
March number one teen does that work sir
[Music]
hey bro listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b-25
mitchell Panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how do they know who you
are yeah
okay um there are these things called
cookies where like if you go to a site
and buy something it'll remember you and
then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address would you like to sample
our vegan bacon 100% meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I I
don't think I can give you any more I
want one
I love food and stuff it's where I buy
all of my food and most of my stuff hey
can I get these how much are they
two bucks apiece good deal anything else
nope just the crows and the beef do you
fish
April no she shot gross let me give you
a piece of fishing advice instead I
don't when you have a fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about maybe not
maybe you really do hey Tandy maybe
moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know
[Music]
motion sensors do you live here
April yeah
do you live here no catch
yeah I thought so I went home but I had
this strange feeling that there was
something wrong with you so I came back
it's just a minor medical issue aids no
I'm safe
blindness no it's like a parasite or a
virus or something you get from a bee I
have a hernia
do you have syphilis I said it's a
hernia I know it's possible to have two
things do you need a ride to the
hospital yes please
okay but I rode my bike here so I have
to go home and get my dad's station
wagon thank you I you're still here yeah
I just wanted to see if you could tell
are you still here
you